You've been told you need eight hours of
sleep. But what if spending more time in
bed is actually why you wake up
exhausted? Here's the truth most people
never learn. 6 and a half hours of great
sleep beats 8 hours of broken,
fragmented sleep every single time.
Sleep researchers call it sleep
efficiency. If you're in bed for 8 hours
but only asleep for six, you didn't get
8 hours. You got 6 hours of sleep and 2
hours of horizontal anxiety. The
counterintuitive fix. Spend less time in
bed, not more. When you compress your
sleep window, you build up sleep
pressure and your sleep becomes denser,
more restorative. There's a simple twoe
experiment that reveals exactly how much
sleep you actually need. Not some
average from strangers, your number. The
full breakdown is in the main video, but
remember, it was never about the hours.
It was about what you did with them.